des pistes de ski et il ya aussi les
chalets ya les personnes qui seront
sauvés et à même les télécabines entre
stations de ski monde sous-marin château
fort ou jungle féerique l'exposition
playmobil un noël fantastique c'est 100
m² de nombreux univers à retrouver à
l'hôtel de ville de versailles j'ai
préféré à l'atelier du père noël lui
cherche sûrement beaucoup aimé il ya
plein de sortes de primes aux vielles
imaginons ya quelqu'un qui aime bien les
châteaux forts et bien il va trouver son
secteur avec les châteaux forts une
exposition qui mêle toutes les
générations je savais pas qu'il y avait
ça à versailles et pourtant je suis dit
suis dit si c'est mon ami qui me afep
kimi a fait penser et donc on s'est
retrouvés ici et je regrette pas d une
même certains pourtant très familier de
la mairie je m'amuse beaucoup parce que
maintenant que je rends dans la mairie
on est accueilli par les personnages
playmobil mais grand oui ils font la
moitié d'une taille d'hommes
et donc oui ça sent un peu comme en plus
ils sont à dessein par une chose comme
ça c'est un côté très festif un espace
qui réveille des souvenirs nostalgiques
de jeunesse kato fort parce que c'est un
peu mon rêve d'enfance qui a pu se
réaliser j'avais pas de châteaufort gd
j'avais dû reconstruire en carton pour
mes playmobil amant un playmobil ça
traverse les âges moi même j'ai joué
quand j'étais enfant je passais des
journées entières autour de ces thèmes
est donc là ça me replonge un peu d'en
bas dans toute cette belle époque
impossible de savoir combien de
playmobil ont été placés dans l'enceinte
même pour le créateur de l'exposition ça
c'est la question piège auquel je peux
absolument jamais répondre parce qu'on
vient avec des caisses et des caisses et
on ne compte pas le nombre qu'on en met
à 20 mètres cubes de playmobil déjà
qu'ils sont sur la table l'exposition
est gratuite et accessible jusqu'au 2
janvier prochain et pour tous ceux qui
veulent ramener un peu de cet univers à
la maison des playmobil à l'unité ou
encore des pièces de collection sont à
vendre